matthew boyd throw again give me really
good on opening day in five and
two-thirds innings throwing 92 pitches
against cleveland in a win
a 1-2 got him looking
a good start for matthew boyd on this
wednesday afternoon
the 2-2
popped it up on the infield
ramos
in front of the mound nice job the o2
pitch
swinging a ground ball hit hard to short
knee high bounce willy castro easy flip
to scope for the force on garlic good
first inning for matthew boyd and the
tigers
last year when he finished second
in the cy young
award voting and was a great year and
came out and gave his team a chance to
win on opening day
and he missed his target there with the
target down and in but he got a swinging
strike three anyway
the old backup slider that tricks a
hitter every time you're expecting it to
break you're expecting it to be in a
certain spot
righty righty first pitch of swinging a
fly ball into right garlic there squares
and catches in front of his left
shoulder for out number two
castro leads off of first two out no
score the pitch is swinging a weak
ground ball speared by a leaping maeda
throws to first for out number three
maeda a gold glove finalist last year
makes a good play
no
on the ground soft hands for willy
castro
here's the o2 swung on and missed the
change of three pitches
second out
that's really using all of his pitches
he's got the fastball through the
curveball early in the first inning and
just a back-to-back change he was first
pitch hunting a lot yesterday and is
here a little lazy pop-up behind second
five pitches for matthew boyd
and he dusts aside the twins in the
second those balls that landed on the
track if it's a different wind direction
does the ball leave
chain jump got him struck him out on a
3-2 pitch
second strikeout for maeda kielba
swins intentionally walked robbie
grossman to get to him with a runner at
third in one out
maeda sets the one-two swing a line
drive to the gap in right center field
running second heading to third is scope
badou around first heading to second
scope will be waved around thirds he
gets all the way to the wall throw the
third base produce slides in safely
rbi triple hard kill badou
he just keeps on going one-nothing
tigers in the second just incredible but
my goodness the fans are going crazy
we're going crazy i've never seen
anything like it
the one two line drive
fair ball down the left field line
landed right on the line big hop to akil
badu he'll turn and throw to second
simmons on the way throw one hot strike
got him wow he could do it all again
fielded the carom off the stands a one
hop strike to jonathan spelt to cut down
simmons and the badou cheers
you know what dad i've never seen he
liked it
the 2-2 and boyd wins the battle
second straight inning he retires the
twins in order
to attack the zone right that's what aj
hinch and chris fetter have been
preaching
nelson cruz and it's speared by jamer
candelario
he'll make the throw to first and cruz
is done
to be able to scoop that up in between
hop that's an incredible play
and plays very comfortably there and
matthew boyd is very comfortable
eight pitches and he's done with the
twins in the fourth
that's incredible if they do that the
rest of the year i think they'll be all
right
and a breaking ball and a quick
strikeout of candelario there that's
what we're used to seeing i'm looking
for this one pitch
reaches back 93 miles per hour in a
beautiful spot and he gets strike three
seven in a row set down by maeda
driven to the right field corner and off
the wall buxton will dig for two
and he's in with his fifth hit of the
year and his fifth extra base hit of the
year
ostadio
high fly right center field
it's grossman who's out there making the
catch buxton coming home
no problem the game is tied with
buxton's opening double leading to the
tying run strike one the count on ramos
1-1 tie bottom of the fifth
hammer to left does it have enough it
does
2-1 tigers on wilson ramos's second
homer of the year like a little hanger
right there chef 84 miles an hour
hanging on the inside part of the plate
and wilson's seen a few of those
eyes got big and out of the park mad boy
who's gonna have to bear down here get
that double play ball
a 1-1
grounded sharply to short castro to
scope the turn is there in time
and two on
polanco is due for some hard contact and
the lefty delivers someone to get into
left center field and that ball is going
to get down that's going to roll the
wall
garlic is going to score the tying run
nelson cruz is going to be waved around
the throat of the play
is not in time
so the twins have taken a three to two
lead on jorge polanco's double cabrera
this afternoon they fly out to right in
a strikeout
to left field diving a tamp cave comes
up short
castro to third being waved around
cabrera
with a double
the throw to the plate and they got him
cabrera into second with a double and a
perfect strike from i believe simmons
in left field and they cut down the
runner at the plate and his hands are
just incredible the way they work i mean
he he got this ball it was in his glove
and the exchange was so quick and then
made a perfect throw to home plate
a fastball lifted to right field
[Applause]
and cabrera
is coming home and here is the throw and
he's out by 10
feet cabrera doubled his last time up
they'll do it again
grounded to short
polanco's turn in time
inning over and we've played eight in
detroit
[Applause]
got him to chase
a pitch in the dirt
works out twins favor
[Music]
a man there a bullet to center buxton
tracks it catches it and there's two
away that leaves things up to jonathan
scope
and that is it
colimay pins it down with a two inning
save twins bullpen pretty good again
here this afternoon they faced nine men
and got nine outs